did you watch the game last night Joey
yeah what do you look for I mean
nowadays I just pretty much watch the
defensive washing so I should just amuse
I mean I'm playing both of the both of
those teams so it's not a bad idea to
get some looks on offensive line I do
borrow moves if you see something you go
I'm gonna trip when's the last time you
did that you looked at somebody who said
you know what I should try to do that
yeah I think last night honestly like I
said I'm playing all playing those
tackles when I see that move work again
so pretty flawlessly better obviously I
want to try it again when I want to say
so I ever have conversations with
quarterbacks any dialogue rest of us in
this offseason
well no no during the game he meant yeah
yeah yeah yeah
kept going about my but not much
dialogue see this they don't like me
that much so you just said hi to Russell
Wilson I was a junior in high school I
was visiting Wisconsin and I guess he
just mentioned remembered so funny
seeing him again after six years or
however long it was five years he's Joey
Bosa I should have given the full
introduction late the Broncos coming up
on Monday night what do you make of the
crowds or lack thereof in Los Angeles
Joey
I think it'll fill up fill out in in our
stadium I mean it's impossible to get
tickets now but um I mean we'll see
obviously it's the way game coming
Monday but I'm not really worried about
who's in the crowd when I'm playing how
much you watching keeping an eye on Ohio
State
of course I gotta watch every move
unfortunately I miss
the game since we were playing but I get
to get filled in with everything from
and and your brothers make a name for
himself as well how often you talk to
him I mean I talked I catch up with him
almost every day so I mean he's always
sending me practice film and we were
just talking about his days and stuff so
minutes this is kind of a daily thing
for us the same time and just usually
talk about nonsense
could you see Urban Meyer style working
in the NFL what do you mean by could he
coach in the NFL be successful his
demeanor and personality yeah I was
talking to somebody yesterday I think
how Belichick and coach Meyer can be
very similar when you come into a
program and you either become part of
the culture you get chewed up and spit
out which is kind of what it's like at
Ohio State so I can imagine that's
similar to what it's like playing for
belcheck so if I think Belichick has
done a pretty good job of NFL so I think
yeah he could probably pull it off I
don't think you'd ever want to now you
have too much control it's like Nick
Saban is great in college because you
get to control everything and these
coaches are control freaks you get to
control less in the NFL developing young
guys into men which is I mean his goal
or Ohio State so I think he enjoys
watching process.can your brother be
better than you I think so yeah but I
mean there's a lot of really only a
couple see in a couple of years I think
he definitely has he definitely has the
tools so people always ask me like
that's a bad thing that he would be
better than me like that would be great
do you collect jerseys from other
players I have three jerseys in my
locker
Ireland September last year
I got Mike Thomas and then I got Bella
Spence so just three Ohio State guys oh
so you're not collecting from anybody
but former Buckeyes yeah
taking my pads off after the game is too
much of a break
what if Brady says hey can I get your
Jersey so Brady would do it but not
c-span usually takes the other person to
ask if you'll ask I'll do it I'm not
going well have fun and in Denver there
and good luck this second season
certainly great rookie season and good
luck against the Broncos that's Joey
Bosa Chargers defensive end the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience